thank you Mr Speaker after 10 u-turns in
two weeks we're left with a prime
minister in office but not in power and
families are paying through the teeth
for her mistakes her latest broken
promise has put pensioners in the front
line of Tory Cuts so can the Prime
Minister perhaps turn to her Chancellor
right now get permission to make another
U-turn and commit to raising the state
pension at the rate of inflation
prime minister I honestly don't know
what the honorable gentleman is talking
about because
in our Manifesto that we will maintain
the triple lock and I am completely
committed to it so is the chancellor
[Applause]
it's no surprising that the prime
minister's approval ratings are
collapsing with an answer like that the
worst polling result for any prime
minister in history she's just thrown 12
million pensioners under the Tony boss
[Applause]
I also want to hear Mr Blackford
[Applause]
or just pensioners feeling the pain in
the last week alone inflation has risen
to a 40-year high mortgage rates are at
the highest level since the financial
crash and people's energy bills are
about to rise to more than five thousand
pounds can the Prime Minister answer one
simple question why does she expect
everyone else to pay the price for her
failure
stuff
I don't think the honorable gentleman
can take yes for an answer I can Claire
Claire we are protecting the triple
and if the if the honorable gentleman is
concerned about the economy why does he
continue to advocate for separatism
economy into chaos